questa è la faccia di un uomo che perde
10 diamanti 10 diamanti nello scorso
episodio di minecraft perché degli
schifosi esseri che spuntando alle rocce
ti ammazzano mentre scico il tuo amico
dalle caverne vaffan
l tutti ragazzi è ben vero che questo
nuovo video sono faringei quello che
perde 10 diamanti non ho la minima idea
di come io abbia fatto perdere 10
diamanti però il discorso è che adesso
sono card avevamo fatto tutto un
episodio di quella torre li vado a
controllare un attimo in questa casa
soprattutto perché i notte ho bisogno di
ripararmi nati o poi continuiamo la
costruzione della nostra magari nelle
caverne ci torniamo sicuramente ma
magari un alcun attivo più di calma io
stesso non sia proprio il massimo nelle
fughe o c'è una certa che la lasci qua
non c'è una porta che segnerà buonasera
eccoti ecco il buon march buongiorno
buongiorno bongiorno monego inseguiti
let's get my friends è molto divertente
entra in casa degli altri soprattutto a
dormire io l'avevo mai vista mai mai
visto che abbiamo fatto niente volevo
fare cose ma sai come sono morto
oddio grazie purtroppo anche da questo
giusto bellissimo arabi e l'attore
stampa in sette lo fa lo stesso anche
sono sì sì sì anche se non proprio
esatto sarà posto ok posso darti un
qualcosa per ripagarti data germanò va
bene così sì te lo do te lo do ecco qua
per fare questa è casa ma allora questo
è l'ingresso di quello che voglio fare
per te lo devo spiegare cosa voglio fare
la mamma ebe medico e c'è un ponte che
ma è ancora ancorati work in progress
vieni qua c'è il tunnel eno che ci porta
poi in una torre gigante è un po grande
tessari tipo sauro è un po un po grande
si sa mai fatta tutta roba i sì tutta
tutto tutto tutto solo ma che hanno
aiutato buddy in realtà programma ok
adesso stacchiamo un attimo che ti
faccio 20 contest orizzo come
d'altra parte di fare un po di percorsi
cioè perderne della star e quella è
un'altra storia
dobbiamo salire così ti faccio vedere
che cosa voglio fare
ok ok il parkour serve ok
vabbè quella sto decorando tutta piano
piano deve essere decorato tutto da qui
fino in alto in alto ci sarà una punta
che sorreggerà un'isola che sorgerà a
casa mia è la madonna
ok la bella idea effettivamente l'esame
lei spiega che c'è anche un ma però
perché lì fianco quell'isola ci sarà un
dirigibile alla bioshock la chiudiamo
gradite sì sì ci voglio provare
no ho sbagliato senato dello stato
cosa vuoi rubano niente niente niente
che non ha ovviamente il mio lei non è
niente a me non importa si sentiva mi
dai una mano a cercare delle cose che mi
serve tipo di volo da fare mi servono
allora mi serve della sabbia per fare i
verdi perché la legna per fare recinti e
poi sostanzialmente basta perché io
voglio fare una roba molto strana voglia
pagare la casa su un albero e una casa
sull'albero e unirli tutti e due da un
po per un ponte ci stati nicola presso
te lo posso regalare anche tanto in
tanto
grazie legnano tanto sabbia non ho
quindi mi devo fare un una pala che
facciamo c'è la palettina ok abbiamo
possiamo anche fare una roba da far bene
qua
ok e poi volevo chiesto e tu non hai una
mazza da fare mi accompagni a fare un
paio di spediva andiamo andiamo
velocissima mons
sono vivo e razzie ha portato
attraversati non ha curato a posto tutto
bene quel che finisce quasi morto sono
vivo però e sono caduto da un chilometro
incredibile ecco io però mi racconta ci
voglio credere
no mi sta rubando tutto non è vero non
trovato niente a ecco cosa ti volevo
chiedere mai di allora praticamente c'è
un cavallo che qua vicino
fernando e lo devo sia nominare che
addomesticare
fare la stalla la presa produzione
rendere la sella è la stella la prendo
nel meter medico
in realtà la sala puoi trovare in
qualsiasi d'angelo gesto che sarebbe e
non come era capitato anche di averla
tipo di una cesta delle piramidi mi pare
quelle cose dove si è però penso che poi
vicino siamo nella giunta potrebbe
esserci il dungeon della giungla
potrebbe esserci e andiamo facciamo che
possiamo andare in giro un attimo
vai andiamo sta roba andiamo viva
intaglio tu sali l'obiettivo di sta roba
è prendere materiali se riusciamo
ok li trovi roba utile e in più al mese
le chiedo perché devo creare la strada
domestica
va bene necessario fai così tu sali tu
sali un attimino fra le due cose io vado
a cercare se trovo all d'angelo intanto
va bene ok allora ragazzi qua ho fatto
quasi tutto io direi che a questo punto
mi mancano aveva tanto posso portarmi
anche una cartina integra direttamente
amy fabbrico larmente siamo in giro mi
porto ma si 64 stacco vanno bene non
importa tanto non siamo ingorghi mi
porto la roba il pane ma serve il
secchio d'acqua non partono perché con
la lava si può esportare il secchio e
allora allora questa finendo di dove
diavolo è la fornace che ha finito di
fare lì vetri vediamo se mi sono bastati
per che abbiamo fatto in questi giusti
sono né tak 1 2 3 4
mancano due metri e ho finito di vetri
mentre in casa dai andiamo in
esplorazione vedere se riusciamo a
ripararlo ma si adatta male con stesso
magna o con mar cile però posti
effettivamente una tv max mannschaft c'è
una aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
aspetta
ho trovato filtro e torce prospetto
aspetto fitto le torce ho trovato una ma
cosa vuol dire che quando servirebbe non
si sono chiesti in giro 96 torce il 6
toro sa essere ombra aspetta soltanto
guarda i gol non ti preoccupare tieni
quale senti hai inattiva aspetto società
milani 2
[Applauso]
[Musica]
cavalcando la mia spalla non basta
dobbiamo metterli a tacere pure però
aspetto che si devo fare tutto non la
spada mai prima di testa dunque ragazzi
siamo vicino a casa cioè vicino a 500
blocchi da casa un po di meno non mi
onora ronco demonio o quattro fuori
te l'ho tolto io sono forte ha ucciso
almeno in orbita uccidendo bravo bravo
se arrivasse con un cuore e mezzo dice
di tumori voce un clip mi hai salvato la
vita come il ferro grezzo vaio allora
metti la metti la kraft debole faccia
mostra fornitaci o facciamo sta roba
perché hai una freccia nel non posso
dire dopo nel comunque se vi era ok quel
sedere di allora ne ho tre però c'era
dell'altro ferro vi aspettavate
raggiungerlo l'unico problema che siamo
stati un po stupidi andare senza armato
pure senza niente cioè no vabbè ma c'è
ma ho capito come facciamo avere la
maturità una carriera hai ragione o no
money senso è anche quella di prima io
avevo 10 diamanti poi non ce li ho più
non diciamo ricorderanno questa retta a
quest'ora ero pieno di diamanti armato
rete ok o altre otto pezzi di diamante
arrivo che si di diamante magari sì sì
grazie grazie amico misura non l'ha
fatto apposta
ok allora domanda ma nelle miniere ci
possono essere ces tesi di ci sono i
dungeon le ceste quindi posto nelle
miniere c'è delle oracle è durato un
trattore ma dio o la named tag
la lista per i piedi cavallo c'era una
versione in tag 9 incredibile perfetto
perfetto pro tutto prendo anche il
carrello ma dovuto tutto ma di drone in
di la prima del video mi ha detto devono
trovare la sella l'armatura verso la
meta che ce l'abbiamo
mancano
manca la sella e se ricevere cure per i
diamanti nell'altro via vera quello
forse un po troppo però già va bene così
posso chiamare il mio cavallo fernando
fernando vice anche se il nome come un
cavallo fermato e voglio fernando è
un'altra storia
devo trovare già guarda quanto feroce
bene pieno e piero e voi prova andare
dall'altra parte vedo si trova un
dungeon vahidi la sicily clicchiamoci un
attimo che io prendo quattro ed ilary by
centro montano klose intende e tipo
risponder degli animali scusa mob e ci
sono un sacco di testing gen
l'ordine di cuomo aspetta prossima spero
ciuro te lo giuro aspetto l'ho visto
l'ho visto ho visto ho adocchiato cielo
ciao o trash
l'ho visto km cielo chi meglio se nuovo
allora se muoio è colpa tua
anche se non è colpa tua è colpa tua
perché l'altra volta sono schiattato
malissimo o tre diamanti raccoglie
pensino a prendere missione di
salvataggio confavi j
va beh veramente pazzesca ragazzo ho
trovati tre che l'ha tolta la 10 ma va
bene non sono non fa niente ok ecco meno
trovati 3 ottimo pescavamo il carbone
perfetto arrivavo anni malato parte dei
maya che sto per darvi gli non l'ho
ancora vista d'altra parte era alta
quindi ci tocca andare ci tocca andarci
se ho cantato che figata
allora abbiamo diamante né intaglio
perfetta della sella per ognuno guarda
si stanno combattendo in due stanno
facendo tutto loro due in un social
banda stick a yahoo.it due frecce
ma in realtà se se lo ammazzo distrutta
penso che ci dia la testa no no non
funziona più che getta il credito tutte
le doppie mamos l'amore la scommessa
come le prende però grazie ce l'hai
tieniti ecco allora io andrei da questa
parte di chi non l'abbiamo ancora vista
che mi pare mi pare ci fosse esatta una
discesa da questo basta si stimava pieno
io prendo intanto il ferro è tutto che
ci spostiamo mai prendi tutto ok si
cuoce tipo una discesa non sono andate
al sabato
vediamo
siccome di realmente è forse ci conviene
scavare perché qua non c'è di vento da
noi c'è un killer dietro è che se ne
esce il device cavalca bravo scavo
scapito del mais cava su sera su raiuno
è tranquilla oppure di diamanti paura
ormai guarda pit stop ma quelli che hai
visto
io guardo al volo ma non c'era niente di
interessante di un anno mi sta succendo
diamanti ok
ogni volta che ci sta roba qua c'è
sempre qualcosa di chi non è vero
no madonna mi stavo scappando sui piedi
ce la fa certo sei pazzo ma tu sei il
battisti basta che scava dall'altra
parte lei pare questo è pazzo pazzo io
voglio vedere il panno il canale come se
niente poi aspetta fammi reagire a
questa roba atomici
ho avuto un tuffo al cuore che non ha
idea se impazzito no no giuro che sono
impazzito nuclei che sento giovio casinò
come sentito così terribili potrebbe
esserci un digiuno allora
emma si risentì così fa aspetta un
attimo e mi sento ancora l'ansia della
lava di prima sei veramente un pazzo
ciao mi sento tantissimo giorno ma sono
proprio che ci si cacci che ad un
creeper in testa che è santo nodo giu
fai una cosa a me sembra di sentirli
sotto mi sbaglio ma non siamo messi male
sentire subito scusa o gemos celano
stone ai piedi che cosa hai provato
no non lo so zombie zombie occhio non
aspetta se no io mica go non a caso
entry faccio la misura che ci vai tu vai
tu perché io ce chiamarti o vado io ti
odio casi non buttarli no no no non
farlo
aspetta tranquillo ti vedo ti venuti da
dietro
ok ok ok che aspetta faccio il giro
faccio un giro faccio un giro perfetto
ma qui diciamo sfogo nel sito non troppo
ma ho fatto la genialata gli o chiusi
tutti lì sotto ho visto scendere ci
credo
ecco mi aprite eccellente lo spacco la
sua sola fra spaccatutto quotidiano la
sella 96 la sella aspetta due erano che
si sono rotte flesso scherzava c'è la
golden apple ha anche una ragazza tutto
tutto tutto in un episodio tutto tutto
tutto tutto niente tutto pazzesco
quindi basta doveva uscire nolan è
meglio dell'altro meglio dell'altro
dobbiamo uscire qua dovevo uscire guarda
allora non scaviamo c sulla testa
facciamo una strada che ci porta verso
tanto l'uscita sappiamo più o meno d'ora
ok sino a malo all'ultimo temi sono
calato sulla testa è stata una romana
tragedia ma due bambini non ti
preoccupare ma tu vai tu e poi vengo
forse guarda guardaroba bellissimo sono
troppo contento ragazzi affidando stiamo
facendo trasmissione saranno momenti
minuti mezz'ora non di più di mezz'ora
in mezz'ora trasferisce una via l'altra
volta ci abbiamo messo perché poi coi
tagli ragazzi non lo vedono almeno
un'oretta qualcosa storta mezz'ora tre
diamanti la stella e il mail a nei tag
pazzesco ci hanno veramente ragazzi
siamo fuori veloce e aspetta che ci
metto non siamo ancora arrivati a capi
ha corso nella serie non sono nella
cesta io non canto vittoria letto non
amo
manca poco fa morire con le ortiche le
ortiche pure le ortiche
io voglio vengono parole ecco la ci
siamo sta arrivando notte oggi che lo
sta facendo novela ci sembra che
veramente siamo contro ogni adesso
aspetta che devo andare a prendere poi
speriamo che tornando sopravviva la
notte vabbè ormai viva è sopravvissuto
fino ad oggi immagino che lo strumento
che aveva ucciso qualcuno ha ucciso ma
infatti dove lo faccio la postazione per
fernando il e falla sotto proprio sotto
casa tua per mega recinto tutto però
essi sono troppo contento di piuro
speriamo che la gente non sappia che che
ciò ste robe
no non lo sa io non dico niente se
andiamo a dormire tutti quanti episodio
ne prese pisodio metto il nome al
cavallo e che non è male va dai ragazzi
io e marci siamo stati credibili
ceramente classi e fatelo benizio nieri
partire fa tanti un'altra volta e
prodotto da una con l'altra volta stef
ha detto scaviamo c in alto per uscire
se invece ti sei scavato in un modo
intelligente quindi alla fine sei stato
meglio di stefan questa spedizione non
si può dire altro va bene così quindi
c'è un posto episodio
ringrazio marcia verificato questo non
sa neanche la sua gara e ci vediamo ciao
faremo anche appunto il tutto a roma per
fernando del social action un bacino
iscritti al canale è certo semplice ciao
ciao belli
[Musica]